All right Ralph, if you would please introduce yourself with your name in today's date in our location.
Okay, Ralph Coleman, also Ralph Coleman, Jr. dates July 8th and we're in my long-time residence in East
Northern neighborhood in Portland and we're going to discuss O H C E and 3 H State and so on.
Yes, talk about your father and your association with the University of Mac Corvals as well.
So let's start with your dad. Can you give us a little background on his upbringing, where he was born and where he was raised?
Okay, he was born and raised in Canby which is a suburb of Portland, South and basically a farming community.
He had a small family, he had a younger brother, two year younger brother.
His father, P L or Philip Coleman, had come west from Ohio and probably before the turn of the century.
And it was an educator and it was the superintendent of the schools there in Canby.
That's where my dad grew up when the Canby High School graduated and I think they're very first graduating class in 1914.
And it's not entirely clear what year he was born.
Well, I've pretty clear it's 1896. There's an affidavit from his aunt who raised him and stating the birth date and so on.
But back in 1896, there were no birth certificates. So the records were either kept in a family Bible or written down some plays.
But he turned up on the 1900 census somehow as having been born in 1895.
So he could use that. If he wanted to be a year older, he'd use the 1895 date.
If he wanted to be a year younger, he'd use 1896.
And his mother died when he was about four or five years old.
And there were the family that my grandfather had married him to sort of took the boys on and raised them.
And his primary character was his aunt Ella in Canby.
It sounds like athletics were important to him from early age.
Well, I would seem so.
In that era, I don't know if they played football or anything like that.
Yes, they had a baseball team. There's a picture in these archives of him in his uniform and with his team.
And played baseball for the local team. Herde's arm or shoulder or something.
And was not expected to ever play baseball again.
So he made the decision to go to Organizer Cultural College in 1914. Do you know why he made that decision?
I mean, he never talked about it. He's probably closer than the U of O.
The decision to go to college period.
The decision to go. I don't know if that's interesting. His brother never went.
And his dad had been to college, but it wasn't a tradition.
You know, the family, none of his extended family in the Canby area, I don't think it ever meant to college.
So I don't know what motivated him to do this, just the smart, you know, ambitious kid.
People liked him when he took off.
He made it in dairy husbandry.
Well, he'd grown up in the farm community and on the farm.
So this was a natural thing for him.
And there's pictures of him on campus with his hat tied, judging a cow or something like that.
So he came out with a degree in dairy husbandry in 1918 and was immediately drafted into the army in the World War I.
And went to Fort Lewis, now Camp Lewis, the time for Lewis.
Infantry, basic, you know, the meat grinder route. The war was climaxing in 1918.
And the big offensive were going on, so he needed a lot of people.
And he was infantry basic, applied for OCS officers candidate school, accepted into that.
And that prolonged stay just long enough for the war to end before they left.
But he was commissioned a second lieutenant and the machine gun battalion or something like that.
And Matties do avoid the war at the major party.
Did he ever talk about his academic experience as a student?
Well, I don't remember any great, you know, long comments about that.
It was primarily an agricultural school, had a technical component to it.
The agriculture was the main thrust.
I don't know. That's a good question. I don't know what it didn't hear that much about the coursework.
Well, we normally associate him with baseball, but it sounds like he perhaps his greater talent was in track and field.
That's true, it was. He even talked about this. He went through it. He's never run it all.
He never competed, never been in a race, never did anything.
And somehow got acquainted with some people on the track team, the cross-country team.
And they said, come on, run with us. And he ran them into the ground basically.
It was a natural. And so they said, okay, you're a come out track, you know.
And he had developed into quite a respectable distance man.
His best time in the mile was in about 420.
And I think my son was looking up the world's record of the time was about 415 or 14 or something like that.
So this was a very respectable level of achievement.
And there would have been an Olympics in 1918 that he probably would have, you know, tried for the American team.
And probably better, pretty good shot at it. Of course the water caused that to be canceled.
So that was the end of that. But no track was his major athletic activity at Oregon State.
He was captain of the track team, competed in the long zone and all that sort of thing.
So yeah, that was his first athletic activity.
Did he ever express any regret that he couldn't have tried to be on the Olympic team?
Well, maybe in passing. But, you know, that's the way it goes.
We all have good shoe to wood ifs, you know.
We only played baseball for one year at Oregon State, OEC.
Yes, I think that's correct. He was playing. He told me he was playing intramural baseball.
You know, not the varsity of the intramural. And that arm felt good.
You know, his injured shoulder apparently had healed up in the intervening years.
And the coach saw him play or heard about him said, you know, going out and pitch.
So he pitched some games for them in his senior year. And it was pretty effective.
I don't think they played more than 20 games, you know, a season.
And then later on, he was good enough to play professionally for three or four summers after we got out of college
for the Portland beaters, which at the time was a triple A club.
And good success, good enough to be looked at by majors.
At that time, a team like Portland would own the players outright.
And the major leagues would buy the players from the teams they wanted.
They would buy them from the team. That's how the team made money. He was selling the players and the majors.
So he was looked at by Detroit, I think.
And they wouldn't have been in Oregon State. He was on the staff by that time.
I think he turned away from that.
More secure position at OEC and professional baseball at that time.
More secure position. More secure position. Yeah.
The baseball, those days, you paid nothing. Prears were short. You know, there were no pensions.
You don't know anything. You just played for a while and then you were going on and that was it.
So he figured he was pretty well positioned where he was and stayed on.
He got married, getting by that time too.
Tell me about the Osolito club.
Oh, I don't know very much about it. Just heard the name.
I think that was the closest I can think it might have been kind of a eating club.
You know, they live there. What they call co-ops might have been a co-op.
And sort of a semi fraternity. And that morphed into the Gamma Talk Beta.
Well, I think he was still an undergraduate when that came about.
And then the Gamma Talk Beta, the next day of course, became Delby Upsalon in 1922.
And that was a big part of his, you know, association with the regular state.
Well, through his living situation, he encountered a couple of few pretty extraordinary people.
He mentioned his best friends were Speck Keen and Douglas McKay.
Well, they were close.
And Speck was from Salem.
And he was a good athlete, a student buddy president.
And they became good friends. He was the best man at my day as a wedding.
And they were, their family and our family were lifelong friends.
They saw a lot of each other. Speck was always around.
And he became athletic directors, you know, at a regular state, very close ties.
In fact, his daughter lives in Krivala. She'd be a good person to contact sometime.
If she'd be willing to, you know, provide information for him.
Doug McKay, I think he might have been a little older than my dad maybe a year or so.
Of course, he would often become governor and secretary of the interior and under eyes now.
So, any other recollections of Speck Keen and Douglas McKay?
Or stories about your father's association with them?
Well, Speck was just a marvelous person.
And loved fishing and hunting.
And was just all around a good administrator and a good guy.
And they did a lot of fishing and hunting together.
Every summer, for a number of years, we all go to Nesquan.
Are you familiar with Nesquan? It doesn't look any different.
You know, today, I did that for a couple of weeks.
And we, you know, eight or ten families from the Oregon State and from Salem and various places.
And that was our summer outing that was Nesquan.
Some of the houses we stayed in in the mid-30s are still there looking just exactly like they did back then.
So, there was a lot of interaction, you know, a lot of closeness in the time.
Maybe people still do that, I don't know.
How did Ralph meet his wife?
I don't know. She was a student at Oregon State, a tri-delt.
She'd grown up in Colberg and went to the University of Oregon for a while.
And then transferred to Oregon State, I'm not sure why.
She was about three years younger than I did.
And it was a very come-we young woman, a series of pictures of her after a while, as well.
And so, you know, I don't know the details.
They dated and got married in their, in her parents' house in Eugene, I think it was.
Later on, they first lived with us in Corbalas, a little better part of their lives.
And a very nice, extended family situation.
Did he talk any more about other social activities or more about fraternity life than his school years?
Well, he'd tell the usual pacing stories and things like that.
It didn't sound all that much different from my own experience, you know, 40 years later.
But it was, I think Oregon State was a fun place, I don't think they took life all that seriously.
But we see in those years, it was an ag school primarily with a big military complement.
Engineering was certainly on the picture, but I think it was mostly a local people.
Local kids went there.
Did he mention his ROTC experience?
Yeah, he thought that was great. He loved ROTC. He was good at it.
He had a lot of kind of a command, presence, and just resonated with his mentality, I guess.
And the ROTC, I think, was what got him in OCS.
I may have saved his funds if they were at Fort Lewis campus.
Well, I mentioned that the World War I experience kind of came and went.
In 1919, he returned to Corvallis.
Got out of the military in that fall.
The war ended in November. I think he got out probably in maybe later on in the year.
Anyway, he went to boot back to Corvallis and was hired by the Corvallis schools in their intramural,
or their PE athletic aspect of coaching and things like that.
And, you know, it was no background, whatever, and education.
And I think he did that for a year then was hired put on the staff at Oregon State
in the physical education department.
And they kind of tasked with developing intramural programs and expanding that into those facilities
and activities available to the whole student body.
He did that pretty much the rest of his career.
He was head of intermeds and numerals, head of meds, physical education.
So he was in the PE department in 1919 and was there until 1966.
So he found a home.
Yeah, intramurals are pretty extensive these days at OSU.
It's kind of like, intramurals are very extensive at OSU these days.
And apparently, we had a rough one to thank for.
Well, he got them started. He didn't finish it.
But that was what he, that was his original.
In fact, there's a little side for you.
You know where the tennis courts are.
And it would be west of, it would be just north of the football facilities and all that.
That was the original Coleman field.
Really?
Yeah.
It was the inner mural field.
That was the original.
I don't know if it was ever formally, you know, just called that.
And then when he, you know, went to the coaching and then he was there forever,
then that became Coleman field.
No, no.
Interesting.
A little side there that's kind of fun.
He lived at the Gamma Talbayda House during this time.
Yes.
I know a little about that.
But like I say, during the while he came back after the war.
And he re-associated with the fraternity.
In fact, lived there.
And he didn't, wasn't in college or anything, but he just moved in.
And that's when they assigned him this promising, but kind of socially awkward depression,
minus calling.
And my dad wasn't at school, but he was, you know, supposed to look out for a minus and socializing and, you know,
getting going in school.
And that's when he reported that to the house that he didn't think this guy isn't going to make it every state.
Never studies.
All he does is repulp Westerns and sleeps a lot.
So he totally missed the mark on that one.
The line was so easy for Pauling that he didn't have to exert himself at all.
And as you know, he was coaching or teaching undergraduate chemistry, I think,
by the time he was a sophomore or junior.
So he, and it was a good guy, I guess, you know, a popular guy.
And one of the guys, and you know, think of two-time Nobel Prize winners as one of the guys normally.
I think he always cherished that relationship, you know, because he was shy and sort of, you know,
a misfit when you're that smart and that, you know, that level of achievement.
And I think it's, you do, I think, find yourself kind of on the outside.
So to whatever extent is true, I think the Gamma taught me is socialized him.
And would you like me to expand on that a little bit?
Absolutely.
Okay.
I met Linus a few times.
We weren't close friends or anything like that.
But he never forgot to ring a state.
And in the Gamma taught beta, it became Delta Upsilon in my team,
22 National Opportunity.
And Linus Paul Lang and my dad and a number of other people were chartered members.
And there's pictures somewhere in the cell of this group, you know.
And his, in 1966, it would have been the, that was a 40-year, 60s, yeah.
I was later in that.
Well, it's in my documentation or somewhere.
They had a reunion or an anniversary.
It might have been the 50th, maybe the 60th, I don't know.
Anniversary of the founding of the fraternity.
And, you know, all the alums in the Portland area and so on were there.
And they rounded up as many of the chartered members as they could find.
And there were about eight or ten of them, something like that.
Linus is one, and my dad is one.
And each one of them took their turn at the mic and told stories, you know,
about their experiences at the Bedouin State.
Linus was particularly funny because when they were applying to the national fraternity,
they had to list the achievements and attributes and all the potential members.
And they wanted to have, you know, some athletic experiences for everybody.
You know, he played this and he did that.
Linus had no athletic background, whatever.
So my dad was assigned the chore of teaching him to run hurdles.
So they could claim he was a track man.
And Linus described, you know, in a very funny way, he and my dad,
bounding around the track, you know, or Dr. Alice jumping over, over hurdles.
So they could claim to be a hurdle.
So he had a, Linus had a good sense of humor.
And he told some interesting stories.
He told about, he talked for about 45 minutes, just unscripted.
And I just, I'd give anything you had a recording of that,
because he talked about his, his experiences with passports and beaches.
And he was on his way to Stockholm to get one of his Nobel prizes.
And they landed in Oslo.
And nobody met him.
Nobody from the embassy came to greet the plane or anything.
He was, you know, not a good repute at the time.
And so he went on to Stockholm on his own.
And then he, he was also given the prize he got from, the award he got from Russia.
The Lennon Peace Prize.
Lennon Peace Prize.
Okay.
And so he had been awarded the Lennon Peace Prize and was, you know, requested to go to Russia
and receiving, he couldn't get a visa.
And he just couldn't get permission from Russia to enter Russia.
And here he is going to get the Lennon Peace Prize.
They wouldn't let him in the country.
So he contacted one of his science colleagues in Russia and said, you know,
what the hell's going on here?
I'll come, I can't, I can't, come.
They won't let me come.
So the guy said, I'll look into it and he got back to me.
He said, well, I got two the Linus Pauling files.
Yeah.
One is Linus Pauling, you know, peace, loving, advocate, the world peace.
And so on the other is Linus Pauling, capitalist running dog.
This one, somehow the application got in the comments of the capitalist running dog file.
So they wouldn't grant it.
They got it straightened out.
But I thought it was, you know, it's kind of a typical Cold War snafu.
They weren't, they weren't on the same page anymore.
The rest of us were.
So anyway, he got there and got the Lennon Prize.
And of course, this was a controversial event.
You know, when was that the 60s?
Yeah, 60s or 70s, maybe.
Yeah.
And that didn't go down well.
And because he was being criticized for, you know, his nuclear test band proposals and atmospheric testing and so on.
So he was, he was controversial enough that it was.
And I was a student at the U of O as a grad student later.
He came through on some kind of a speaking thing.
And it was controversial, sort of, in the 60s, the 50s or the late 50s.
In fact, he was a little side story.
It's kind of interesting, you know, my fraternity.
There was a picture of Linus hanging in the Dan.
And, you know, for other dignitaries.
And this would have been in the early 50s.
And his picture was taken down by some of the members hidden away somewhere.
It disappeared because of this, you know, this attack from the right.
And I don't think it phased Linus at all.
I think he just plowed it on through, you know, I don't know.
So he, you know, he knew he wanted to do and he did.
He has, you know, everlasting credit.
And he and your dad maintained a connection over the years.
Right.
He and your dad maintained a connection.
Loose connection.
I don't think it was ever, you know, there was a history there at early days, which, you know, you don't, you remember those things.
But I don't think there was much, you know, correspondence or much contact.
Because he was, you know, operating in a entirely different, different level.
Well, back to your dad in the early days in Corralis.
He coached freshman track for four years, too.
I think that's right.
I don't have all of that in front of me.
Some of those information I gave you.
I think that was probably his first coaching job was, was track.
Did he maintain an interest in track over the years?
Yes, he did.
Yeah, he, he loved, he loved helping with track needs and helping put them on high school track needs.
So he was, yeah, that was his first athletic well, I think.
He's also an outstanding golfer.
Yeah.
We became the head baseball coach in there in the 1920s, but it was a different situation back then that is now.
How do you mean?
Well, he's essentially a volunteer job for one.
Oh, right, right, right.
I'm not sure it was a paid job.
I think he often, often said that it was not, he was paid, you know, to be an administrator, a teacher and the physical education department.
And an academic appointment there.
So baseball was just sort of an aside.
It wasn't a very, I don't think high-powered program.
There's photos in this thing that show the baseball field in 1920.
There isn't even a backstop.
You know, Waldo Hall is there and you see the building and the heating plant with the chimney and all that.
But nothing else is around there.
So it was a very, you know, low-key operation.
And he didn't want to be paid for it largely because he said that then there'd be an expectation.
He didn't want that.
He wanted to be able to do this as a, as a hobby, you know, as a fun thing.
And it was and got him a lot of notoriety, you know, made him a lot of friends and a lot of fun for him.
But he didn't want the, they eventually didn't start paying him, you know, years later.
But it was not a big, a big amount of money for him.
That wasn't his job.
That wasn't how he made his living.
And I always thought that was kind of shrewd.
You know, coaches get fired because they don't perform.
And he didn't want that.
You know, get, find somebody, if you get somebody for the price you're getting me for, go for it.
But he didn't coach non-stop from 1922 on.
He ever several periods there when he was head of other administrators.
Do these in the 30s, Slats Guild coach, I think, for about six years.
Yeah, that was fascinating.
Discovery Slats Guild, also baseball catch.
Yeah.
But it was a very low key sport.
Like I say, 20 games, maybe, if they were lucky.
And they just played local teams.
Was there any recruiting at all?
Well, I don't know.
Or my dad recruited.
He would recruit locally and scout around high school kids in the summer and that sort of thing.
So, nothing like, nothing like today.
It's light years removed from, you know.
Are there any scholarships offered back there?
I think, by the time I got there in the 50s, I think there were some scholarships.
They'd have a handful.
They'd split it up into little pieces.
Most, I think, you had to work for them in those days.
If you were getting a stipend ride, they'd call it a year.
You had to put in a certain number of hours, you know, cutting grass or doing something.
And, you know, they made us, we had to do that.
Well, tell me about how his coaching career evolved over time.
I mean, the baseball became more formal and he became more established and the program became more established.
Well, it was just an evolution.
I don't know if they were long-time rivalries or some great pictures of one.
There was a picture in there of Buck Bailey kicking the bucket, you know, and the water's spraying out.
And so there were, or again, lots of good rivalries there.
And people liked the game.
But it just developed and got, you know, their vision was there.
And then eventually in the 50s, late 40s, they formed a Southern division.
The California schools rise there.
We didn't play them.
And then in that era, they started to play postseason games.
And the college world series came along in 1946 or 1947, something like that.
The George W. Bush was captain of the first Harvard team.
I think they won the college world series.
It was the first baseball.
George H. W. Bush.
The first, first Bush.
H. W. Yeah, not W. H. W.
Right.
So, college baseball got a big shot in the arm when that national competition started.
And they had good years and bad.
And it was a lot of fun.
At any point did he feel like that he was baseball coach, was his job
and the other job was less of his job?
Well, yeah.
I don't think so.
You always pay attention to where you're, who signs the check.
But baseball was what, you know, got his reputation and his social thing.
You know, his players loved him.
And everybody knew who he was.
And he's a very personable guy.
And people responded to him and liked him.
And so that makes life easy.
It's only more about his personality.
He was an intense competitor.
He said, oh, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
He just, on the bench, he was just a constant motion.
You know, throwing grass in the air and stomping up and down.
And attacking the young players and challenging calls.
You don't see that anymore at all.
But all the coaches used to do it back, you know, in the 40s and 50s and 60s.
But after the game was over, no problem.
Everything was fine.
But I think that was, I always thought that was kind of a negative.
I mean, your coach is just constantly, you know, spinning out of control practically.
And your sports remain calm.
You know, in any control.
But you know, his intensity was infectious and a question about it.
And what do you want to win, too?
Well, obviously Corvallis is in a rainy place.
And baseball is played during the spring when it's often rainy.
But do you never, did he have a facilities component to his job, too?
I'm sorry, taking care of the field, obviously.
Well, the players did most of that.
They were on a scholarship or a ride.
And then we did a lot of that.
So you can imagine what kind of shape the baseball field was in.
We used the armory for our spring workouts and things.
The season didn't start.
We didn't play any games until the start of spring quarter.
Now they play 60 or 70 games a year now.
And we were lucky if we played 25 or 30.
It was fine with me.
It's good to get the season over.
You want to do other things.
What was travel like back then?
No buses, cars.
We took my senior here, I guess it was.
We took our first out of state trip.
A spring break.
There's a week in there.
So my dad is scheduled to several games in California.
So we piloted in these cars and took off for California
and played Stanford, Cal and Sacramento and Fresno.
And we didn't have any budget at all.
This was the first out of state trip, you know,
except for the conference play.
First, you know, they do this routinely.
Now they go all over the country playing in tournaments.
And this was an interesting experience.
I think it would have been 1953 probably.
And we'd pull into some town like Berkeley,
where we would play Cal.
And my dad would say, okay,
the game would be at the field tomorrow at noon.
Games at 2.30 or something.
Be there at noon.
See ya.
We were on our own.
We didn't have a hotel.
We didn't have anything.
I think we had some meal money.
I think you might have given us some meal money.
And we were supposed to fend for ourselves
that we did by staying in fraternities.
You know, you know, I fall in and call it the U House
and say, you know, I'm down here with the Oregon State baseball team.
And we come and camp there for a couple of days.
Oh sure.
And the guys have worn in fraternities.
We just bring them along.
Pretend like they were.
So that's how we got by.
In Fresno, we finally stayed in the hotel
because I think he wanted to know where everybody was
when they came time to go home.
But other than that, we were just,
just freelancing it.
That's funny.
I can compare that to the day that everything,
but they're private jet, you know.
How did they, how did the colon feel itself?
It wasn't called colon feel them.
And how did it change over time?
Well, I think you just got just fell into the usage, you know.
Before it was dedicated, you know, formally dedicated.
Yeah.
Just, did he have to raise some funds?
Do you recall to have improvements made?
Or I don't recall anything like that.
I think it was just based on what the,
what the athletic department would provide.
Actually, they put a backstop up.
They put a backstop up.
We had seats, bleachers, and all that kind of thing.
But it was, it was pretty primitive.
There was no fence out in the outfield.
Oh, really?
No.
And the ground was hard.
And while it got past the outfielders, it was all run.
But you couldn't get one out of the park.
They were all inside the park.
Yeah.
So that was made an interesting, you know,
addition to the, to the challenges.
So you wanted fast outfielders.
Yeah.
You mentioned that training was pretty casual.
Yeah, there really wasn't any.
You know, we just started, we'd work out the gym or the armory
and I'd have stress running because that was especially for pitchers
because that was, you know, good for you.
But no, you know, half the team probably smoked, including my dad.
And that was just, you know, we'd take smoke breaks during the game
under the stands.
I love the buses and things like that.
So a little more casual.
Yeah.
And this is both teams would join for the smoke break, right?
Well, yeah.
I guess I hadn't thought of that.
But we were on the first base side in those days.
And now they're on the third base side.
And down up the south end of the field,
they had the wooden football stadium stands that went around there.
I don't know if you picked them up.
There was, we'd go down under there and the stands and, you know,
be out of the other side.
Was this, was this scheduled before the game,
or was there some signal when I thought it was time for a smoke break?
I thought it was just, let's go.
In between getting, you know.
Well, his most successful team was probably in 1952.
The team won the PCC championship in the State of Western Regional
and went to the Colossal World Series in Omaha.
You were a member of the squad anyway.
Right.
I was a member of the squad.
It was actually, I was JVing at that year.
Didn't play, you know, a play against the varsity
and with them and practice, practice and things like that.
No, I didn't actually play with the team.
And the numbers that they took back to Omaha,
I think they were restricted.
So again, it was a fairly small squad.
There were players that played, you know,
the longest part of the season that didn't go back.
They got hammered.
They lost the first two games.
It was hot and so on.
They got there, that was amazing.
They didn't make it back for another, like, 30 years or 35 years
or something like that.
Well, do you remember much about that season?
I mean, it sounds like it was sort of a magical season.
They just came together and some really good athletes.
Those days, it was very common for guys
to play more than one sport.
And let me see.
Our catcher was a starting-end football team.
First baseman was a starting forward.
Second baseman was a starting guard, the basketball team.
The third baseman was a linebacker, football linebacker.
Left fielder was another tight-end.
And so I think out of, if you take away the pitchers,
I think there were three starters on that team
that didn't start for some other team.
So without those guys, we would be helpless, you know.
So yeah, you could play and they loved baseball
because I got them out of spring football and that sort of thing.
So they all wanted to play baseball.
And it was a fun sport.
What do you remember hearing about the Omaha trip?
Obviously didn't go all the field, but it was...
Well, I think they went by train.
Well, I'm training the very hot while they were there.
Omaha, you know, at the time of year, it could be pretty bad.
And I don't think their accommodations were very good.
I think it was only about the 50 or 60-year of the college
middle series.
So I don't think they'd really gotten their rhythm down yet.
And I remember them talking about the heat.
They couldn't sleep.
We had these heavy wool uniforms.
Just one uniform.
You want something warm as you played out here.
But back there, it was totally inappropriate.
I think that hurt them.
Do you remember being a big deal with that?
Made the World Series on campus?
Oh, yeah.
We played the U.S.C.
Southern Cal, we were the perennial champions.
And we played them in Crivales.
We played them in Los Angeles the year before.
They beat us down there.
And we got them again in Crivales in 52.
And I think we had 5,000 people there.
They put the stands up, you know,
dragged them in from all over.
And huge crowd.
It was a big deal.
Yeah.
That must have meant something else.
It was.
It was a great fight.
A couple of no-worldly players that I came across.
Maybe you can comment on.
Do you know much about Wes Schoenrich?
Yeah.
I knew Wes.
He was lived over in the coast.
I think over on the Ness Tucka.
And it was a fishing guide and an outdoor type of guy.
And he'd come to all the games.
Big burly.
You know, oysters.
Guy.
And it was also a great football player.
I don't know if he played in the pros or not.
But he was.
He did play pro baseball.
He did play major league baseball.
For the Philly sand.
Another name I came across was Ed Coleman.
Ed Coleman, right?
Yeah.
His half brother.
He was several years younger.
And played for the Oregon State.
And really good career in the majors.
He played about five or six years.
And he played for the Portland Beavers after that.
He had a good career.
He was in the record books for a while.
He was a great pinch hitter.
He was a American league pinch hit.
He was a single season pinch hit record for about 30 years or something.
So he had good success.
Athletic family.
Yeah.
Did you have a particular style as a coach?
And any sort of philosophy of baseball?
I mean, would Pat Casey his favorite sort of a small ball approach?
Was there anything like that?
Just beat the other guys up.
You know, that 52 team was a good example.
He was the guy for huge.
You know, the starting four were just six five.
And the football players were six three, six four.
For the day, these guys were huge.
It was big pitchers and everything.
Physically.
And we would make sure that when we'd take batting practice before a game,
that was always pretty game rituals since each team would take batting practice.
You'd watch the other team.
You know, yeah.
And we'd make sure that the bigger the bigger the guys were,
the earlier they got out.
And yeah, so we've dropped these great big guys out, you know.
And they'd be in the ball all over the place.
And it was intimidating, you know.
So yeah, he liked that kind of team.
So he didn't, we didn't play much small ball.
I think the idea was just to, you know, overpower him.
Yeah.
Who were some of your dad's best friends in Corralis?
Well, he was there for a very long time.
And as you said, he's a popular guy.
The only belong to all the clubs, the Youngst club and the Rotary Club.
And, you know, if there was a club, he'd join it.
And most of the close friends we had.
There were a lot of them in the department, the Lantons, Dixon's,
other coaches, Slasvio, you know, we just,
Lonnie, Steiner, the role of close friends, the coaches.
And he had close friends just among the townspeople.
He was a small town boy and liked a small town association.
What was your impression of Slasvio?
Terrific guy, I like Slas a lot.
I used to caddy for him.
And he'd always give me two bucks.
I think that was it.
So, and he had two kids who were a little younger than me.
But of course, I knew them and everything.
Slas was a really good guy.
He just, you know, found his niche and stayed in it.
Just, you know, did great.
And they'd be on, they'd be, you know, standard participants in the annual beach trips
and the parties and hunting and fishing.
And they did all this stuff, you know, all the coaches
and people did all these things together.
Now, Slas was a really, really good guy.
I kind of think there was something I was going to say about him,
but it was, oh, maybe a little anecdote you may not know.
UCLA was looking for a basketball coach.
And they ended up hiring John Wooden.
But Slas turned it down.
These teams had beaten them.
UCLA, two years in a row over the championship.
So, he'd be decided to incrementalist.
I don't think they'd get offered any kind of money
but he just decided to stay out and he grew up in Salem.
So, he was a, you know, very much a local boy.
So, Wooden went on to become, you know, a legend.
But Slas preferred the smaller arena.
How about Lonstiner?
Did you know him at all?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, Lonstiner was just a really nice guy.
He was lots of fun and we'd go hunting and fishing, you know.
My dad and Lonnie.
And he just, he liked, he was, you know, when you're a kid,
you know, when there's people growing up so like you
and others that are just kind of going through the motions, you know.
And Lonnie really liked people, liked kids.
Just the terrific guy.
Well, it sounds like outdoors were important to this group of men.
Were there other hangouts that they frequented besides the lodges?
Well, Elves Club, primarily that was the place where everybody gathered.
It was right in the center of town at the time.
They didn't know if the building was still there, but it was right, you know,
on third street or fourth street.
And so, this was just the focus for all social activities in town.
Get moose and others, but the Elves Club was the one that most people frequented.
My sense of the athletic department during your dad's time
is a pretty tight-knit group.
Is that accurate?
You think?
Yeah, I think so, yeah.
Paul Blondie, of course, he came in in late thirties, played basketball,
and Navy, and then came back and never left.
He still went, I think, isn't he?
He's in the ball, still alive.
He was the J.B. baseball coach, was he not?
He was. He was the freshman.
He was the only assistant.
My dad had, and I don't think he got paid,
but he was the tennis coach, assistant basketball coach,
and assistant baseball coach.
So he was your coach, isn't he?
Right.
What was he like as a coach?
A good guy.
You know, baseball hadn't been his game, but it didn't matter.
You know, he could manage it.
I remember we played a game against the...
as a freshman, they had freshman teams in those days.
You'd only play three years of RC,
so you played your first year as a freshman.
We went over and played in the penitentiary.
You know, in Salem.
They played a whole...
The Zang was that they played a strictly home schedule.
So we were in there, and it was fun.
You know, let us...
I'd never been in the penitentiary, and you know,
the field was out in the corner, it was huge wall.
And the umpire was...
I was pitching the game, actually.
And the umpire was, you know, the convict, and so on.
And they just...
on each other totally, they'd bother us, you know.
But they were just razzing each other.
Everybody had a nickname.
And so it was a...
it was a fun experience.
I don't know the baseball...
I don't know if the prison grades, I don't know if they still have a baseball team or not.
Your dad was also an official.
He officiated football and basketball.
Yes.
And that was his...
it was a hobby.
I mean, he made money at it.
And yeah, quite a good reputation.
He was a football official with several rose bowls.
And yes, that's why he finally got out of that on the late 30s.
It was two more to physically demand me, you know, the football home of the basketball.
No, he did a lot of money.
He was a commissioner for referees, for a while, for the conference.
And he would evaluate officials and rate them.
And that was some things that are overseer.
Well, he retired in 1966.
And he mentioned he was a good golfer at...
he seems to have turned his attention to golf at that time.
Well, he always played golf.
Like, I'll take that back.
He's...
I don't know when he started playing golf.
He helped lay out the Dallas Country Club.
Really?
And it was really good.
And coached your taught golf.
You never coached golf.
You taught golf for years in physical education department or in state.
And played it a lot.
And it was good.
Anything like that came easy to it.
You know, when your athletic attempts to generalize, you know, all the areas.
And do you play golf?
A little bit.
But you know what a shank is.
Well, he developed the shanks.
Terminal decays with the shanks.
And he didn't play for about 15 years.
Just walked away from the game totally.
He was a regular golfer, you know, a couple times a week kind of thing.
And took lessons and tried everything.
And this couldn't get over it.
And then when he retired, he kind of got him back into golf a little bit.
When he retired, they left Corvalis, my mother, and sold their house and moved to Woodburn,
a senior state.
And he was hired there as the golf to take over the golf program.
So yeah, that was his retirement venue.
Yeah, golf is important to him.
He liked that game.
The beginning was so competitive that it kind of, you know, you can't be overly good.
You can't try too hard, you know, and go off as a game.
You have to play below your, you know,
your maximum effort.
Yeah.
And so I think that was kind of made it harder.
Do you know anything more about the laying out the Country Club?
I mean, just didn't that story.
Only that they planted the all those, they planted fur trees.
Layout, of course.
I don't know if it was with them.
The members and the volunteers, the volunteers, they planted all those fur trees in the rough.
And it was only nine holes, you know, begin with.
And very yellowy and clay.
And it's just like concrete, you know, to play it.
So, you know, that was laid out in, probably mid-twenties.
So he was a charter member then.
I think it probably was, yeah, probably pretty close.
Well, Colin Field was dedicated as such in April 1981.
I'm sure that meant something to him.
Do you have any reason of that particular moment that it had been?
Yeah, my son and I went down.
And we're there.
There's pictures and documentation, you know, in the material that is there.
And Robert McVicker was the president.
And Jack Riley was the coach.
And it was during, I think it was secondary to a game.
I can't remember exactly.
I think it was.
Very nice event.
The speech, he was a very good presenter.
And could tell jokes.
I think, I don't think there's any record of what he said at that event.
But there's some other information.
There's some, he would write it out ahead of time.
So there's some things in there.
He could, he was good.
Good on his feet.
Do you think I meant the lot to him that the field had been named after him officially?
Oh, I think so.
Yeah, we wouldn't.
You know, that was a source of pride, I'm sure.
Nice honor for him.
And after that, it sounds like he got another job in baseball.
The Portland Mavericks.
Are you familiar with the history of the Portland Mavericks?
No, okay.
Well, he, being Russell, who was an actor, Western actor,
the Portland Beaver franchise had been kind of left vacant.
He picked us up for practically nothing.
I think it was partly to provide a venue for Kurt, his son Kurt Russell to play,
who was quite an active baseball player.
And the Mavericks were independent, the own team.
They weren't owned by any other major league team or anything like that.
And these were just free agents, some pros, some amateurs,
and being Russell hired somebody to manage the team.
And he would be around and these players up.
And they played and they, it wasn't AAA, it was, I mean,
a AA level down at the moment, we'll see.
And I think there's a movie being made about, you know,
books, things like that.
And they were a very flamboyant, you know, bunch.
And when, at one point, Frank Peters didn't need anything.
Okay, he was an Oregon State baseball player,
basketball player played on that final four basketball team.
And had played professional baseball and he was hired as the manager.
And he hired my dad to be his third base coach,
because he played for my dad.
And so there's a Mavericks hat around the house somewhere.
So he spent two or three seasons, you know,
helping manage the four Mavericks.
That was later on, pretty late in his life.
Right, yeah.
Okay, so let's turn the attention to you now.
You were born and raised in Corvallas,
and I just didn't know the Corvallas that you knew growing up as a boy.
Small town, all the way.
Everything just revolved around the campus.
Summer time, everything just quit.
Everybody just handed their yards and laid around.
They didn't have much in the way of summer school.
They did have a summer school and one of my dad's assignments was to work
with the summer students and setting up field trips.
They'd go to, you know, a bodybuild dam in Timberline Mods,
and over the coast, and he'd organize.
He just loved this kind of thing, you know.
And so, but it was a nice place to be in the summer,
or whatever was going on.
And the Corvallas calendar was Oregon State's calendar.
New Year's Day was when school started in the fall.
It wasn't in January because everything just focused on the activities on campus.
And most everybody worked for the camp college.
One, you know, directly or indirectly.
It wasn't any excuse for Corvallas being there, but for Oregon State.
And it was a very nice place to grow up.
The campus was our playground.
The kids, you know, we just knew how to get into every building.
And we said, you know, we needed to get into.
Our parents didn't know what we were doing.
I don't think they wanted to know what we were doing.
So it was a playground.
As you got a little bit older and to say,
the high school age, where were the places that the kids congregated?
You mean in Corvallas?
Well, there were some, there were some, there were some drive-ins.
And there was a drive-in theater up between Albany and Corvallas.
It was a fun place to be.
There were places downtown, restaurants, I don't remember having any particular.
It was kind of like American graffiti.
It was a lot like Corvallas.
It was a lot like the American graffiti, you know, ambiance.
It was a very nice place to go up.
Everybody kind of had their activities, you know,
everybody's garden, their mothers all collected antiques,
and played bridge, and most of the mothers didn't work.
Faculty wives, there weren't jobs.
First of all, it wasn't, I don't think it was considered quite
socially acceptable for mothers to be working.
It was kind of an admission that you needed the money, you know what I mean?
So, there everybody had lots of time.
There wasn't much, there weren't very many organized activities.
You know, we kids, we just did what we wanted to do,
and say, well, be home for dinner, you know, when that was it.
What sort of impact do you remember the depression having on the town?
It sounds like the faculty referred a little on some of the economic impact.
Well, that was my impression.
You know, I didn't, I wasn't hardly aware of the depression.
It was just the way things were.
I was born in 1931, of course, that's just when it was in its worst.
And it didn't affect the university college that met much.
Everybody, I don't think they had much of the way of cutbacks,
I think, although I couldn't document it,
there were times when they did not get paid at all by the state.
They were given IOUs, and I think they were honored later on.
But that was, it was, it kept breathing.
And of course, there were migrants in Crabalus,
and they show up at our back door and want food and that sort of thing.
It was, it was there.
And of course, World War II came along and ended that and I heard...
Well, that's my next question.
How did this, how did the town respond to World War II?
What was it like during that period of time?
Well, of course, there were no men around.
And they had a ASTP program.
That didn't need to.
It was an Army-sponsored program for soldiers to go to college,
and I think they became officers at the end of it.
So there's an ASTP program.
But these are soldiers essentially assigned to that role.
And as far as men went on campus, that was about yet.
The women lived in the fraternity houses, and the school kept going, but the war was
having a big impact on it.
Was it there in the midst of its growing noise?
Yes, the Campadero was had a huge impact on Crabalus and Albany, and it was a basic
infantry basic, I think they put four divisions, infantry divisions through there, three or
four years, it was right, and that's a lot of soldiers, and we had one living in our
house, we always had one living in our house with us, not what they get back, we didn't
have the soldier living there, we had his wife living there in our spare bedroom, and
this was pretty typical, the wives would follow the soldiers out to be around during their
basic training, and these guys would get released from Campadero for a weekend or something,
and hear them clump up the stairs at night, GI boots and down the next morning, and so
that was pretty standard too, so the city was supporting that effort.
My mother was a great lady, that's kind of a nurse's auxiliary volunteer at a hospital
at Campadero, and they were at uniforms, they were in the military or anything, but they
would write letters for soldiers and keep them company in the hospital, so she did that
during the whole war, this is a volunteer.
Were you able to go out there at all, or was that off limits?
I don't remember going on the base during the war, afterwards I did, once the war was
over.
I'll take that back, we didn't go out there, because we were in the gym doing something,
oh I know, yeah, my dad had, during the construction of it, they had a baseball league, or softball
one or two, and my dad coached one of those teams, one of the construction teams, and so
I was on the Campadero a couple of times, and one time we were in the gym, I guess it would
be, and there was a whole slug of POWs in there, we were storing POWs at Campadero to the war,
and these were African Corps guys, Germans, and by the way they were a tough looking bunch,
and then there were also Italians around, and they were more open than friendly and stuff,
so they were being housed there, and I don't know if they were escaped or not, but like
the security was very tight, they had a pretty well, pretty good as it was, that's interesting,
I hadn't known about that.
They expansive it there, it's amazing when you see it now, but the expansive it there, it was
amazing when you see it now, it's quite, and there's not a lot there, it was supposed to be
the second biggest town in Oregon.
It was huge, covered maps, they had an artillery range, the Campadero, a lot of it
acreage for an artillery range, and we could get you're blooming away over there in the war.
You mentioned in your memoir that the family traveled to San Francisco for the world's fair
in 1939, oh yeah, do you remember that at all?
Oh yeah, that was a great outing, and we stayed with my great aunt, Liv and San Francisco,
and yeah, that was a nice event.
You taste your own, a lot of artifacts from that, I am.
Well, tell me about high school, in Corvall's high school, you were the senior class president,
I worked indeed, and had a lot of fun in high school, you know, I did not, a lot of
people don't have good experiences in high school, but I had good experiences, you know,
everything wasn't a hundred percent, but, you know, I was on the baseball team and the golf
team, and, you know, had good friends and had a nice time.
We won the State High School Basketball Championship, I was in junior, I wasn't on the team, but
that doesn't get any better than that when you're in high school, you know, to win the
State Basketball Championship.
We made the decision to go to Oregon State College, it sounds like there was, there wasn't
much of a decision to be made, there was no one that was kind of ditched.
That was, you know, I can't think of anybody in my class, high school graduate class that
did go anywhere else, you know, initially, and there were a lot of faculty kids in Corvall
as obviously, so they were going to go to college, but that was the closest one and the
most affordable, so that's kind of what we all ended up with.
What was it like playing in your dad's baseball program?
Fine, had a great time, had a great time, and it was, you know, no stress, everybody
accepted it, and had a good time with it.
That seemed to be the real honor for me.
You played Summer Baseball?
Yeah, that's what everybody did in those days, it was on the baseball team because, you
know, my dad, we want to be playing, and he want, you know, his players to be playing
too, and we'd be hired, we'd be sent out to these small towns, every town had a baseball
team, a semi-pro baseball team, which means the semi-pro means professionals, ex-professionals
could play on the team back in those days that it was a no-no in terms of amateur status,
where it's supposed to play with pros, but they made an exception for baseball, so these
town teams would have some ex-pros and some college guys and some locals, and it was
a big deal for the town, and they'd get us jobs, you know, we're going to the woods
or pulling on the green chain or something like that, and it was about what was out
there, and the mill pond job, that was not a, I was living in Corvallis as Summer, I
know, as Summer, we went to Air Force, basically or not, anyway, that was a mill south of
Monroe, it was a big mill pond, and yeah, that was a, that was a dangerous job, and a tough
one.
Well, tell us more about what that job entails.
Well, every sawmill had a mill pond where they would store logs, and then the logs would
be brought up to the, where there was a conveyor belt, and then would be then lifted and conveyed
into the sawmill and cutting the boards, and the people that moved the logs around were
called pond muckies, and you're out there in your court boots, and you're big pole and
all with, and trying to corral these logs, and you know, push it across the pond, and
get them over to the, where they could be picked up, and they were about five of us, I think,
the pond muckies, and none of us knew what we were doing, and they dumped the logs in a
one end of the pond of log trucks, and then we gathered up five or six of these, or
we had wrapped and propelled across the pond, and then they were a couple of professional
pond muckies there.
They would just split around, you know, and fly across the logs, and we were in the water
half the time.
Interesting experience, and this terrible water, you know, like I said, my mother wouldn't
have been in the house, you know, and come over, because you smell so bad.
So that's what we did.
Those are the jobs that were available, minimum wage, no unions, you know, so you're just
totally the mercy of the, you know, owner, but there you guys, that was, you know, that was
a career for a lot of people, you know, for us at least, it was just a summer experience,
so it was a great incentive to believe me, you know, to stay in college and find something
better, because that's where a lot of these guys are going to spend their lives, you know,
going on the green chain, and this sort of thing.
Probably that's some interesting characters, I'm sure, you know, and then that was, spent
summers in coquillo and Brookings doing that, those sorts of jobs, playing for their town
team.
Some rough and tumble towns.
They were, they were indeed cowboys and Indians and fishermen and loggers and you know,
he spent a summer in primal too, is that right?
Primal, that's yeah, coquillo, Brookings and primal, those are my three stocks, yeah.
Well, you lived at Del Toup's lot too.
I was, yeah, I was a legacy and looked at other houses, but, uh,
they had a nice combination, I thought, the athletes and scholars and waste rules, you
know, didn't take themselves too seriously, that were, you know, a good bunch of guys,
and so I never had regrets about that, that worked out pretty well, a nice group.
You mentioned that, a particular fraternity, I don't know if Prank is the right word for
it, but there's a story involving Skimmer's Mutant and Oregon, yeah, you see Oregon.
You know, they had a, we had a genius for coming up with stuff like that, no, that's a true
story, and when I was a freshman, my freshman class, I didn't have to go on that, but they
went down and blew a piece of it off, they didn't get the whole thing, but they didn't
die in my, some of it off, you know, Skimmer's new, never got caught and made it back, and
two years later, went back and really, you know, got the whole thing this time, and it was,
they also got the way with that, you know, the FBI was interviewing everybody on campus,
and I was trying to get a handle on who, because Dynamite was considered a, you know, a
dangerous substance, and they'd steal it from the stump, the last in class, during the
state, you know, the egg school and some of that stuff, so these guys would steal Dynamite
and the cabs, nutty, you know, just nutty, but they never caught out, they did it, and this
was the big O, it was the big O and, and then the, the guys that didn't went back later,
and they'd gather up pieces, chunks of it, and everybody had it in the house and a chunk
of this, oh, when they're on their desk, the paint, I don't know, it was about that thick,
you know, I mean, the paint, you were back in the calmer days, you know, Oregon State would
be down in a painted orange, and then, Oregon would get up the next day and paint it yellow,
so that it would happen a lot, but I think that was the last time I ever got, you ever got
blown up? The last time. I don't know, no interesting sights, or I was
down at that game in Watson one time, years and years later, and, and I was relating this
story, you know, about my fraternity being the, I mean, Dynamite of the O, the skater
of the O guy behind me, he says, came around, he says, is that a true story? Did you, you
know, you read the guys that did that, and I said, yeah, and he said, I wrote my master's
thesis on that, on the Dynamite of the O. So, it was a story that, you know, had legs, at
least. What was social life like for you in school? Rich? No, very good, Oregon State
was a nice, friendly place, and there were too many men, not enough women, you know, student
body, it was mostly, you know, egg school, the engineering school, and all that, so men
out there were the women, but it was good, you had a lot of fun, it was, if you lived
on campus, which most of us did, we lived in our fraternities, you were not like at different
universe, you know, your parents were glad to have you out of the house, and you were
glad to be out of the house, and you might as well be in Chicago, you know, the amount of
interaction at this place just wasn't any. What sorts of events were important on the
social calendar? All house dances, you know, I said, one major, every house, then one
major house dance every quarter, and those were big events, and, you know, if you were
dating somebody, you'd get invited to her house dance, and she invited you to invite
her yours, and so on, so there's a lot of that, and a lot of beer drinking at Murphy's
Beach, you know, Murphy's Beach is, you know, South of town, there's a tabern, we've
got about two or three miles out of town on the right-hand side, and I call it Murphy's.
Yes, go Murphy's, okay. We'll just pass that half a mile, there's a road that goes
off to the east, the highway, down to the river, and I think there's, I don't know what's
down there now, but back then it was a gravel operation, and this is where all the
people are, you know, took place, this is called a birth speech and nothing to do with
the tabern, but that was where everybody gathered. It's a new one to me. That's a new one
for me. Oh, yeah, that was the place, and you know, if anybody wanted to do a rest of
this or has this right, everybody knew where we were, and it wasn't just my fraternity,
everybody was out there, you know, the football team, the basketball team, everybody, you
know, so there's a lot of party going on, I don't think, nothing has changed, I don't
think. We played baseball in the springs and the summer, did you do anything in the fall
or winter to get ready for the season, or is it just being in all student? I think once
the season was over, we were done. I don't remember any particular, each season, you know,
footballs, football season, basketball season, baseball season, they had to start to stop
time, and you know, we had guys that played three sports, and throwing a state, three major
sports, and started each year, every team. So you can do that then, and I don't think
that's, can they do that now? I don't think so, can. I think very few do if they could.
How about school? What was your academic experience like? I was a moderate success, modest
success, I was in business administration, and that wasn't a very stimulating major for
me, but, you know, I made my grades, and I was only on probation once, so that's not
too bad for four and a half years. But I graduated. Any teachers about that made an impact
on you? Any teachers? You know, Gordon Gilkey. He was a good teacher. This is a long
time ago. Can you tell me more about him? I'm interested in Gilkey. Well, Gordon, you
know, he'd been in Europe during the Second World War, and one of those people that participated
in saving the uncovering the German stashes of art and so on, and really made a major contribution
there, and then he was also a woodblock print collector, and huge Japanese woodblock print
collection, and taught the course codes, surveyed visual arts or something. Anyway, it was
a review of, you know, art and history, and so on. Fastening course, and he taught that
every year, and then, later on, he became dean, I think, of liberal arts to me. I think
so. And he lived right around the corner every entire, or even state. He was a good guy.
Every summer was there. Summer was a photographer. Yeah. Yeah. I can't think of his name now.
I'm going to ask you a little bit about the climate on campus during the time you were there.
You were there towards the end, I think, of the large influx of GI Bill students. You're
mentioned in your memoir, they were somewhat aloof. Oh, yeah. And I'm guessing that you have
a sense of why, from your own military experience. But can you talk a little bit about the GI
influence on campus way right there? Well, it was huge. You know, first there was a huge
number of them. And then, a lot of them are married. They're older. These guys, you know,
they weren't interested in the morning look, lids, or any of that stuff that just went by the
boards. You know, they weren't having any of it. You know, these wanted to get in there and
get their education and get on with their lives. And so that changed the whole campus
tenor, you know, totally. And then here, it went to my group, you know, went to the
high school graduates and never, you know, didn't want to do anything. And they all, the
upper two classes in the fraternity house were all over two guys. And they ran these fraternities
like boot camps. The guy down the hall for me, one of the seniors, I think it's a senior
there by that time in Bob Kyle. He then wound in the battle of the bulge. He didn't mess
around with those guys, you know. And they didn't take any, you know, very serious and very
business-like and they were good role models, you know. We learned from those guys. So,
yeah, they changed the whole campus philosophy and turned it upside down. And then they were,
I started in 1949. So they were kind of a tail end of it. And the ones that came
along after me, none of us had ever been in the military. So occasionally where the Korean
war came along and that changed a lot of things. We had a lot of Korean war veterans around.
So did the workloads tradition die out at that point? I mean, that was very strong before
then. What's that? The workloads and things like that that just ceased to exist.
Yeah, that just sort of, I think people tried to get it back in place. But if I don't think
it everybody, it wasn't the same as it had been. And things were changing anyway. It wasn't
just the World War II events. The whole world had changed. The Second World War just changed
everything. The whole majors didn't matter anymore, you know. New technology was coming
on. And so the very revolutionary, in retrospect, you know, very revolutionary period.
Yeah, well, and you mentioned some, I'm trying to ask about the subject of race. And especially
the example of Dave Mann, who you write about in your book. It was not a revolution on campus
by any stretch, but it's an inkling of a very gradual change that was going to come later
in terms of the topic of race at OSU. Well, Oregon State was a pretty, pretty one race
institution at the time. We had black students from Africa, exchange students, and Asians,
of course, have been around for a long time. So it wasn't totally quite, but it was predominantly.
And there were no black athletes. Oregon had had black athletes in the 30s, football players,
Jackie Robinson's, or brother. Mac was a track man at Oregon. And so Oregon State was, you
know, late to the game. And Dave Mann was recruited out of California to come and be Oregon State's
first black athlete, which he was. And it was very successful. And I didn't know him very well
personally, but he was he stood out on question about it. And he was he was not a he was not
a self-refacing person that a good way to put it. But not a bad person. I mean, he didn't
cause any problems or anything. He just he was new to, you know, this was a new thing
in Oregon State and Corvallis. Confident day. Yeah, very confident. Good athlete. Didn't take any
stuff, you know. You want a campus boxing tournament? This isn't fascinating. There was a campus
boxing tournament. Yeah, Intermural. Intermural. Well, it was, yeah, Intermural. And yeah, they just
three, three about, three roundabouts. Yeah, he won that. Was this a period of time where
there were many concerts on campus? Still were. And what was that like? Did you have, did you have
classes in them? You know, I don't remember having. I think they're mostly used for office space
and meeting rooms and things like that. They weren't big enough for you for a classroom. So just
reflective of a period of expansion on campus. And they have influx of new students. Yeah. I want to ask you about
a couple of things that happened at OSC during your time, a 1950 gilcal seam open. Do you remember, do you
remember that? Well, I don't remember having any major event that, you know, it had been coming for a
long time. It just didn't magically appear, you know, everybody knew it was coming. It was, yeah, it was a
big event. It was the state of the art at the time. You know, that was the Oregon State's athletic
facilities were first class. Parker Field was new. Oregon had riggedy wooden stands still.
California schools have big stadiums but, you know, Oregon State's facilities were pretty good.
The spec key was responsible for most of that. Really? Yeah. Do you have recollections of attending basketball games in
the old men's gym? Yes, I do. So, Slant's fields, teams, knock over, UCLA, twice in a row. Yeah, you get
pulled. It's a hell of 2,000 people. Yeah. There was about anything around all the way around the
men's gym. And, you know, the two. Yeah. So, yeah, you know, I started going there when I was
probably four or five years old. And what's been quite an environment? It was. Just athletics,
so, you know, how about football at Bell Field? Well, it was a mud bowl, so it was, you know. And, you're close to
the field. But the student section was on the west side. And in those days, if you can believe it, the
COVIDs all wore heels and stockings and pants just for the game. Do you imagine that? Yeah, it's amazing. Well,
we sort of wind up here a little bit. I'm interested in knowing about your continued
association with OSU after you graduated. Obviously, we had a career in the military. We went on to other
things and graduate studies in the career. And, well, when I came, I left where you stayed in
1954, spring of 1954, I came back in 1966 or 1967 on something like that. And I lived in Chicago
in Evanston and Lincoln, Nebraska, Pennsylvania, other places, you know, the kind of stops you make. And I was
hired by Oregon Health Sciences University, recruited by them to fill a certain role they were
looking for and came back. And my dad had just retired for your stay so there wasn't any of that
overlap anymore. But he was, of course, very closely involved. And, you know, he had
seasoned tickets, so I just picked up going to the football games and, you know, that sort of thing. But that, I
wasn't associated with Oregon State in any direct professional capacity. But it was still part of
our lives. And then, you know, I was a lifetime member of the life member of the alumni association. The
varsity always kind of kicking in a little bit, they were getting things going. And then the baseball field
project came along. Pat Casey put that together and asked me if I would be on their committee and did
what's, you know, the fundraising committee. And we were successful largely because of the $1
million grant from Goss, John Goss, who sold a piece of property and was going to be a huge tax bill. So we decided
to do something with it. And that got Kit Pat started. And he'd probably been there. This wasn't a, you
know, he, I don't know how many years he'd been coaching. But I'll bet it was close to 10
by the time a stadium project came along. So, you know, you think of the baseball project. And I think of the
whole program as a project, you know, so different from what it was, you know, back in the day. It's patting
me. And overnight success, you know, just came in and waved the magic wand. But that's not the case at all.
He started right from the ground zero. And they didn't even charge for baseball games when Jack
Wright was there. And even in Pat's early days, he could just walk in anytime, you know, free. And, but he is a,
I think a remarkable person, a remarkable developer. I think he would have done well in whatever he was.
He, you know, elected Oregon State that he chose baseball, but he had, he's a talented person, you know,
not your normal, just your regular everyday coach. And he spearheaded this and we meet up here in Portland.
And we, you know, tap people we knew. And, and there were some major donors that stepped up and that
built. So that was a huge, that was a real sea change, you know, the baseball program. They have that facility.
It was interesting because prior to that time, I mean, Jack Riley and Tencelli and others might have
done something similar. But until, I wish one of the presidents who was, who was after Montgomery
earlier, probably burned, could have been. No, no, it wasn't. It was after him, even.
Yes, sir. Oh, yes, sir. I think it was Paul Rissert, right.
Said it would be okay to build a permanent facility on that location. But the university's policy prior
at that time had always been that this was too valuable, a piece of property. You know, it is right, not the center campus,
but it's right on campus. And they wanted to put dorms there and things like that.
Well, so they wouldn't permit any kind of improvement in the facilities. Nothing until Rissert said, okay, you
can do this. And then that opened the door for Pat to go out and begin to, and then John Goss coming
along. But those two things came together and made it possible to put a permanent facility on that site.
You know, it's the oldest baseball field in college baseball.
Well, it is the oldest or the second oldest, I think there might be some dispute about that.
But it's one of the two. And somebody wandered out there one day in 1907 and drove a stake in the ground.
And this will be home played. But it's never moved. You know, it's been a big success.
I think that was good for Pat, good for the program. I think it made it possible to recruit.
And that's everything in baseball. And Pat, now with his reputation, he just recruits nationally.
I mean, he doesn't recruit. He just answers phone calls, basically.
Stounding success. You know, somebody said, everything went to their one of their first college world series.
I said, what was your dad? What would your dad feel about that? Yeah, but he'd be proud and nice.
And he'd be dumbfounded this way, wouldn't it? He just, you know, considering the facilities and the attitudes and so on.
So he's, he's out of remarkable, remarkable job. Yeah.
Well, the last thing I want to ask you about is just your thoughts on the current direction of the university.
Things have changed mightily in the last few years. And there's a lot of momentum heading in different directions.
What do you think of all this? Well, I think Oregon State's got really a lot to be proud of.
I think, you know, the current administration has really been in place long enough.
I think it's been, there's continuity there. There was some, you know, most of the president's in state more than four or five years.
It's that, you know, they move on to other things.
So I think that continuity has been important. And I think they played the funding game very well.
The technology grants and all this stuff. I don't follow up with the microscope, but I don't think they have
the reputation that they deserve. I think it's not, not really their fault. Every, every institution has areas of excellence.
And Oregon State is certainly no exception. But it's not the kind of thing that gets the headlines.
So, but no, I think it's a really fine institution. I know when my older son went there and had a great time.
And so, they just completed a big fundraising campaign.
Yeah, just about a billion dollars. Billion? Yeah. One of the better campaigns around the country, I guess.
Yeah. Yeah. I think so. Yeah. So they do a good job, I think.
I think Oregon State, Oregon State can be proud of Oregon State. And I think it's possible to get a good education there.
I think one of the things that was kind of a negative, when I was there, they had virtually nothing in the way of liberal arts.
And you can only take two years, they only offered liberal arts on the undergrad or the lower division level.
And that that closed out a lot of, you know, it's an age when you really ought to be looking around at, you know, other things.
And the opportunities weren't there. You had to challenge yourself into one of these technical oriented majors. And it wasn't always a good fit for everybody.
So I think the fact that they expanded that, you know, that option is, I think, adds a lot to it.
I think they really made that return the corner for them as far as I was concerned.
When they developed liberal arts college and the good major and so on.
Well, Ralph, I want to thank you for this. It's been very interesting and fun and enlightening for me.
Well, it's been a real pleasure. Yeah, terrific. Thank you very much.
Thank you very much.